como en todos los últimos vídeos que
hemos estado haciendo vamos a comenzar
partiendo de un sub espacio vectorial de
rn entonces digamos que aquí tenemos
nuestro espacio rn y vamos a empezar con
algún sub espacio digamos b ok entonces
vamos a tener aquí nuestro sub espacio b
y ya hemos visto en vídeos anteriores
que podemos construir un espacio llamado
el complemento ortogonal de b que de
hecho va a coincidir con be únicamente
en un punto que es el 0 entonces digamos
que aquí tenemos a b ortogonal ok
entonces la pregunta es la siguiente
bueno vamos a ir escribiendo quienes be
ortogonal vamos a repasar que be
ortogonal es el conjunto de todos los
vectores x de ere en tales que estos
vectores son ortogonales a todo el
conjunto b eso quiere decir que si
hacemos el producto punto de x con b
para cualquier ven en el sub espacio
esto me debe dar 0 esta es la definición
de que sean ortogonales
debes debe de ser cierto para todo para
todo de que se encuentre en nuestro psuv
espacio de mayúscula ok entonces lo que
vamos a pensar en este vídeo es qué
ocurre cuando uno considera el
complemento ortogonal de un complemento
ortogonal es decir tenemos el
complemento ortogonal del complemento
ortogonal y esto por definición pues
serán todos aquellos vectores x de
nuestro espacio rn que sean ortogonales
a los que se encuentran en el espacio
ortogonal a b entonces quiere decir que
x punto w debe ser igual a 0 para todo
para todo
wv en el espacio
en el complemento ortogonal debe ok
entonces algo que hay que notar y que
debe ser claro es que el sub espacio b
el sub espacio b está contenido en el
complemento ortogonal del complemento
ortogonal de b porque sí
si los vectores que son ortogonales a d
pues si tenemos eso es decir si tenemos
todos los vectores que son ortogonales
sabe pues todos los que son de b también
son ortogonales a los que se encuentran
en el complemento ortogonal de veces que
suena como trabalenguas pero lo que
quiero decir es esto que quizás
podríamos tener que el complemento
ortogonal del complemento ortogonal no
sólo contenga vez sino que también
pudiera contener algunos otros vectores
que no estén en vez digamos que tengamos
esta otra región que estoy sombreando lo
que lo que ocurre es que aquí no sabemos
si b es todo el complemento ortogonal o
si tenemos algunos vectores que no estén
incluidos en b y que sean parte del
complemento ortogonal del complemento
ortogonal ok entonces la pregunta es
bueno quizás este complemento ortogonal
digamos podríamos pensarlo como que es
la inversa no quizás podría ser que el
complemento ortogonal del
complemento ortogonal vuelve a ser el
mismo espacio que fuera como la
operación transpuesta que selló una una
idea de ese estilo entonces lo que vamos
a tener es vamos a partir del hecho de
que x se encuentre en el complemento
ortogonal del complemento ortogonal debe
y vamos a demostrar vamos a ver si es
cierto que este x pertenece a nuestro
espacio b entonces lo que ya habíamos
visto en otros vídeos es que si yo tengo
cualquier vector en rn en particular
este x yo lo puedo escribir como una
descomposición única de dos vectores es
decir lo puede escribir como la suma de
dos vectores donde el primero de ellos
se encuentra en b donde éste está en
nuestro sub espacio de mayúscula y el
otro se encuentra en el complemento
ortogonal muy bien entonces este x que
en particular me tome que se encuentra
en el en el ortogonal del complemento
ortogonal de b lo puede escribir de esta
forma en ésta
en esta descomposición ahora bien qué
ocurre si yo hago el producto punto de
este x con w entonces x punto w por un
lado si nos damos cuenta w está en el
complemento ortogonal y x se encuentra
en el complemento ortogonal del
complemento ortogonal de b es decir xy w
son ortogonales y por lo tanto el
producto punto es 0 pero por otro lado
es x como se puede descomponer de esta
forma entonces tendremos b b más w y
hacemos el producto punto con w
y esto pues como se distribuye tendremos
de punto w esto más w punto w muy bien
ahora bien ves se encuentra en el sub
espacio b&w se encuentra en él
en el complemento ortogonal de s por lo
tanto esta parte 0 y sólo nos queda w
punto w que no es otra cosa más que la
norma
el tamaño de w al cuadrado su magnitud
son sinónimos en este caso entonces la
magnitud o la norma de w al cuadrado es
cero
tenemos entonces que la norma de w al
cuadrado es igual a 0 y esto que nos
dice inmediatamente el único vector cuya
norma o cuya magnitud de 0 sólo puede
ser el vector 0 entonces obtenemos que w
es el vector 0 y eso nos dice mucho
porque si la descomposición había sido
hecha de esta forma quiere decir que x
es b porque w es 0 verdad entonces
tenemos podemos concluir que x es igual
a b muy bien pero si x es igual a b y
dijimos que b estaba en nuestro sub
espacio eso quiere decir eso quiere
decir inmediatamente que nuestro vector
x pertenece al espacio b entonces qué es
lo que hemos hecho nos tomamos cualquier
elemento en el complemento ortogonal del
complemento ortogonal de b y llegamos a
que no importa cuál nos tomemos porque
fue arbitrario
y pertenece a nuestro espacio ve esto
quiere decir que el complemento
ortogonal del complemento ortogonal de b
está contenido en el en el espacio b
aquí ya habíamos mencionado que b estaba
contenido en este conjunto pero vamos a
hacer lo dijimos digamos muy al aire
vamos a hacer un poquito más formales en
ese sentido
digamos digamos que tenemos por ejemplo
vamos a tomarnos un ahora uno ve en
nuestro espacio vectorial ve en nuestro
sub espacio y vamos a ver que este
forzosamente está en el complemento
ortogonal del complemento ortogonal ok
entonces vamos a ver vamos a hacer un
dibujo incluso de esto digamos que otra
vez tenemos aquí nuestro espacio rn ok y
ahora vamos a partir no de no del sub
espacio ve vamos a partir del sub
espacio de ortogonal ok y pues sabemos
nuevamente que el ortogonal del
ortogonal coincide con él en solo un
punto que es el 0 aquí tenemos a de
ortogonal ortogonal muy bien lo que nos
gustaría demostrar es que éste que nos
tomamos arbitrariamente en b se
encuentra en este conjunto amarillo en
el complemento ortogonal del complemento
ortogonal ok entonces
nuevamente podemos utilizar este truco
en donde ve yo lo podemos expresar como
una suma de dos vectores y esta suma es
única
entonces esto será w más un vector vamos
a llamarle x donde pues w en principio
dónde
podemos pensar que w se encuentre en el
espacio
wv ok
este es nuestro psuv espacio y por lo
tanto podemos hacer esta descomposición
y vamos a pensar que nuestro vector x
pues está en el ortogonal de este
ortogonal se encuentra en el complemento
ortogonal del complemento ortogonal debe
ok y hacemos vamos a usar el mismo el
mismo truco el mismo argumento qué pasa
si hacemos el producto punto debe con w
bueno b se encuentra en en el sub
espacio b&w se encuentra en el
complemento ortogonal debe entonces
estos dos son ortogonales y por lo tanto
esto vale cero pero por otro lado me lo
puedo expresar de esta forma es decir bs
w x y voy a hacer el producto punto con
w y nuevamente esto como se puede
distribuir el producto punto tenemos w
punto w
x punto w
dije doble 1x ahí está y notemos que x
está es ortogonal o más bien x está en
el complemento ortogonal del complemento
ortogonal the b&w está en el complemento
ortogonal de b por lo tanto estos dos
son ortogonales y este producto punto
vale 0 ok por lo tanto llegamos a que
doble w un punto w que es la norma de w
al cuadrado tiene que ser cero y
exactamente igual que en el caso
anterior te podemos concluir que w es el
vector cero no le queda de otra más que
ser el vector cero ahora bien si w es el
vector cero esto de aquí no aparece y
entonces b es igual a equis esto quiere
decir que ve es igual a equis y como b
es igual a equis que tenemos x en qué
conjunto vivían en el complemento
ortogonal del complemento ortogonal de b
eso nos dice que si partimos de
cualquier b arbitrario en nuestro psuv
espacio b mayúscula
entonces llegamos a quien sin importar
cual me eligiera de forzosamente tenía
que estar también en él
en el complemento ortogonal del
complemento ortogonal debe ok entonces
esto si le sumamos además que el
resultado anterior esto que sí estaba en
el complemento ortogonal del complemento
ortogonal es decir si x si x se
encuentra en el complemento ortogonal
del complemento ortogonal de b habíamos
dicho que entonces que entonces x
forzosamente tenía que estar en b
entonces aquí me está diciendo en el
primer enunciado que si yo tengo un
vector en b forzosamente todos ellos
deben estar en el ortogonal del
ortogonal debe y por otro lado me dice
que todos los elementos del ortogonal
del ortogonal de b tienen que estar en b
por lo tanto estas dos afirmaciones me
están indicando inmediatamente que el
conjunto que los dos conjuntos son
equivalentes que son iguales es decir
el espacio vectorial ve está contenido
en el octogonal del ortogonal debe y por
otro lado el ortogonal del ortogonal
debe está contenido en nuestro espacio b
y por lo tanto ambos conjuntos son
iguales